yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing I am Sherlock to see doing here
that's a rare line moving the Queen
around huh but what to do against this
probably opening up the position is good
too with d5 392 doesn't look right yeah
so night x is not bad very likely but
pawn takes threatens addy for some
default Bishop b4 it's really a weird
way to play probably then though maybe
you thought is success to go to be
played and then pre-move 93 is awesome
another misstep pin sorry he's got a
good score against me pretty substantial
plus plus 3 out of the number of games
yeah there looks like 94 is bad 91 okay
yeah clean b6 is very crude but Bishop
before is a big threat end here Knight
a5 even a zone I mean pimp sorry for my
voice yes that didn't look right might
be three is a big threat ok so here and
then he goes who be 19 f 3 is going to
be his next move probably ok so I'll do
that even the simple g6 is not bad for
line for Bishop f5 probably play you for
against that if I just do this folksy 8
Queen a five checks also something that
is and after against that is yeah
against that you will play the 52
it isn't it looks good it looks good fit
is it winning or anything check the ship
Detroit's not too convincing I mean I'm
better after that but i wonder if you
have something more convincing this
looks very normal but yeah I wonder what
but Bishop f6 I have Queen a fire so
visible sick still didn't work yeah this
might work yeah and now be sure to see
four he goes screen to f5 know that just
just about works 95 doesn't convince and
then I check he has to go to Shanti to
not that it's not not that great so this
next move is cash hold that claim Bishop
f5 he didn't have moves for the Queen
Square as I mean can I let's do it it
doesn't look great I have to say and
this develops wired him to text what I
don't like about it it really develops
hell you and I was more concerned of
light takes
he wants to play against my porn I guess
him maybe okay i know it takes for the
night okay did not expect any of that
and yeah this is kind of hanging that's
a really terrible result after this this
opening i mean i might be better but
even that is not totally clear and that
position that the house was absolutely
terrible shouldn't be in this remarkable
and i'm down on time quite a bit i think
i'm still okay but again that's not it's
not what I should be thinking about
being okay and I shouldn't blunder this
oh my money incredible quite incredible
yeah 93 this is somewhat annoying for
him at least most not that easy now
Knight d4 and night a1 are annoying move
what okay white raisins now that's
really not that wasn't good I mean why
does basically lost here and I didn't
manage to to do it on so let's have a
look at a 395 how do I win so g6 is
doing a job and I that was the first
thing I thought about but I just felt
like it might not be it might not be
clear enough I thought you might have
this and like takes Bishop takes huh
isn't that great but this is a good move
pair 495 now you can watch position this
is credibly bad but ok the engine
actually likes my stuff as well 9700 ok
you should see ya I thought he goes here
what is the thing i Luke c5 ok oh no i
didn't i thought he goes here with ok i
have tons of moves they have tons of
damping all that spread bad person and
he actually is Bishop takes her that
killed Floyd and then it's pretty clear
that there must have been something but
I didn't find it 25 haha we defer for
Bishop f5 again is also very strong yeah
so I really let him get away with this
crap yeah it should equal I'm not sure I
mean I lost the pawn in the game but I
thought I was reasonably active so I
wasn't completely sure how bad it was ok
7 I am cool
of course Luke a 70 cannot go be five
now this is this is probably equal yeah
the pawn is just just too dangerous 70
he blundered this somehow yeah it was
lucky at the end but I mean you simply
cannot play the opening like that I mean
what kind of position is that that's
just not not going to work ok guys
thanks for watching